da-da-da-da-da da-da-da-da-da
da-da-da-da-da
hi I'm telling McDonald and welcome to
this weekend this weekend this weekend
Charlie McDonnell gives us his review of
Pixar's Cars two through five do you
know why it exists Charlie McDonnell
becomes one of those annoying people who
counts his calories because he wants to
lose a bit of weight and Charlie
McDonnell starts a new new show format
called
this weekend in which apparently all of
the news is about himself but first on
the show this week in fashion in fashion
news this week what is Charlie McDonnell
thinking he's decided to ditch the
fetching green skinny jeans that he's
been sporting for the past few months in
favor of the boring old pair of shorts
when questioned he had this to say
Charlie so cool Oh what do you have to
say about the green jeans it's just
really nice out at the moment it's good
weather for sure
behold all the fans of the green jeans
are we gonna see repeat of the infamous
red hair Charlie situation listen I know
this is gonna be a big deal for a lot of
people but you're just going to have to
deal with it I'm a shorts kind of guy
now this week in celebrity news and
that's it for celebrity news that is
worth hearing about this week in wild
life okay for this segment we're gonna
go live now to Charlie McDonnell who's
in the back garden Charlie hello Charlie
and hello London I've got some big
wildlife news for you today I'm up here
in the back garden where just a couple
of days ago I saw my favorite kind of
spider the zebra spider and it was so
great that I went in to go and get my
camera and get this footage of nothing
because by the time I got back the
spider had moved but it was a zebra
spider and it was here in my back garden
back to the studio is that the whole
thing seriously
Thank You telling McDonald for that
reports Jesus that guy is so weird
this week in finishing this video I'm
just going to talk to you normally now
if that's all right I'm not very good at
finishing things if I've made something
and I'm even just a little bit unsure
about if I think it's any good or not
then my gut tells me just to destroy
whatever it is that I've made and start
again on something new but I don't think
that's very good and so to combat that
urge I've made myself this this is my
finishing stamp the idea behind this is
very simple if I finish something that
I'm working on then I get to put a stamp
on it
and because putting stamps on things is
fun it encourages me to finish more
things and that's it admittedly it
probably doesn't seem like a bit of a
weird incentive but for example I'm very
unsure about if I think this video is
going to be any good or not but you are
watching it I've finished it so
apparently finishing stamps work for me
at least by the way this is what I
designed to go on my finishing stamp
it's a stamp of quality ah because I
like puns and I like tea okay the only
problem with this really is that most of
the stuff that I make isn't a physical
thing that you can actually put a stamp
on but it's a digital thing like a video
for example so I guess I just have to
figure out a way to put a stamp on the
video you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
yeah I think that works well enough then
love Charlie McDonald he's my name let's
do that again
Chad McDonald becomes a person who can't
say what he wrote and Charlie McDonnell
spends his life talking to a camera